i enjoyed the roller coaster atmosphere
of
of being estonia because there are
high highs and low lows you know so i i
enjoy the the thrill of that high lows
and uh and the challenge you know we're
building something is something new
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet bensy
benatar the chief marketing officer of
sepio and one of its co-founders he has
a strong intelligence community
background and over 25 years of
experience winning multiple professional
and innovation awards
further benzie has a bsc in electrical
engineering and is an mba graduate he is
a hardware security expert as well as an
expert on rogue device detection supply
chain attacks internal abusers and is a
leader in zero trust hardware access
venti benatar leads scepio's marketing
activities and boosts sepia's brand
awareness
cyber is uh
obviously huge in our world it's going
to become even
more prominent in our world i believe in
a lot of other believe as well you know
in the coming years and we're just
starting to see the importance of it um
and what you're doing with sepia has
something super interesting you know
we're talking about cyber security we're
talking about monitoring and we're
talking about understanding you know
these things both on a on a on a network
level on a company level for enterprises
and so i'm really interested in hearing
both your personal journey leading up to
sepio and these insights that have led
you here as well as what you're actually
doing with sepia today so so betsy thank
you so much for joining me
great so um so let me let me share some
of uh
some of the experiences some of the
history that actually brought us uh
myself and my partners to this uh very
unique domain
yes so
we the group of founders we're actually
working together for almost i think 30
years now we've started out as an
academic reserve
in 8200
and since then we've been working
together on on various various companies
actually sepio is our third cyber
security company together so the first
two were successfully acquired by nasdaq
traded companies
and when we
uh when we've decided to go on our a
our next endeavor on the unsepio we've
actually kind of looked into the market
and said okay we're we're too old to do
uh big data we're too old to do all
those flashy buzzwords
uh but what we do know is we we know
networking to uh to a great intimacy
we've built layer two switches we've
built network tabs we've been all around
this rob a rock devices all the in and
out from from our previous careers
and
we've identified that this domain is a
is lacking the
required
technology and required measures in
order to
detect those rock devices and those
hardware based campaigns
and
we've seen through throughout the years
that this domain which was uh
one perceived just as a you know spy
business you know just like fsv and
you know nsa tools and mossad and all
the mi6 and all of that
sorry it is no longer the case
because a cyber crime syndicate
and even the average joe can have the
same state level capabilities with
regards to hardware tactiles as a as a
you know world financed agency
and due to the fact that you use a an
attack vehicle that existing cyber
security product
a didn't take into consideration and
allows the attacker to bypass a lot of
the security measures because they've
assumed a certain thing so they've
assumed that when they will look into
the traffic they will they will catch
you or they will
you know detect the abnormality traffic
or things like that but what happens if
you're uh you're a passive tap or you're
uh you're an unmanned switch up that
doesn't have any layer 2 presence
whatsoever what happens if you're using
a device
that completely impersonates a
legitimate device even if it's a simple
device like a keyboard or a mouse
these vulnerabilities and these kind of
blind spots within the existing
infrastructure is something that
attackers are uh are happily exploiting
and you know with with great uh with
great success on over multiple domains
it could be critical infrastructures it
could be atm attacks it could be
financially swift transaction attacks
and you know
hardware attacks actually applies to a
variety of
variety of domains
and the fact or the
uh that people are moving into cloud
environment you know doesn't uh minimize
the the effect of this problem actually
it it is even intensifies
because even if you work in you know in
your home or from a shared space and you
have a
you have your cloud
infrastructure in place you still use
your keyboard and you're still using
your mouse in order to navigate and uh
and run your command so a qualified
detector will easily log your keystrokes
take screenshots of your
of your enterprise uh confidential data
and then it will use that to run a data
leakage a ransomware attack or even a
data encryption attacks this is
something that is happening more and
more
that you're describing that is first of
all critical no question about that but
it's also something that i'm assuming is
not new right i mean we've been you know
we i'm sure that this is a problem that
we've been facing for for a few decades
by now you know and why why is why
aren't we more advanced than what you're
describing where the average the average
person has the same capabilities as you
know enterprises in terms of getting
these securities
so there there are several reasons for
that
the first is that hardware
hardware-based attacks obviously
require some physical
a contact or some physical proximity to
the victims and in most cases it will be
a pinpointed attack so you will go after
a certain bank or after a certain
power plan so the the targets will be
very pinpointed
and once they are attacked they they are
very reluctant to share the fact that
they've been breached over their
cyber physical security
and you know we know of dozens and
dozens of incidents that didn't meet the
public didn't get to the public eye
because these are not events like you
know solaris or or you know those
massive look for jade
things like that
and you hear about it you know when
there was a nasa jpl that was under
senate to inquiry then you know you got
some data there you got some data from
uh
stocksnet which was a supply chain
attack so they're like very unique
attacks that uh usually are kept while
uh well hidden
and uh the fact is that because none of
the existing
a security products can can detect those
attacks so you don't have those kind of
flashy
you know animation of attacks coming out
from china and targeting east coast and
west coast and back going back and forth
so uh you know from the
cso perspective this is a problem that
appears in mr robot it appears on
mission impossible or
james bond so you know
he would ask himself oh i'm not of
interest that's usually a pushback that
we get i'm not of interest to anyone
and you know it's always the other way
around if you have something that
that is of value it could be your a
customer database it could be your ip it
could be
um transactions that someone can carry
on your behalf you have valuable data
that someone they will find a an easy
way
we'll go for it
amazing
it sounds like what you're describing
here is sort of
internet cyber security of maybe you
know 15 or 20 years ago when it was just
starting out and people would say okay
but why why would i you know it started
out as perhaps very specific attacks on
specific organizations and then a lot of
these a lot of these um you know
loopholes were found in a more generic
level especially as sas continued and
we're describing this sort of a maturity
of understanding of okay how does this
actually happen and how do we defend
against it and what you're describing
also is that currently a lot of these
organizations are kind of helpless
against these attacks right and part of
it is because of the lack of attention
that that we as csos may be giving to
the the the wanting or the interest of
others to attack us right
yeah and there's a lot of misconceptions
and um you know some of the
misconceptions are you know are or us to
blame for you know the industry because
for example the term rogue rope device
so if you will go over you know the
companies that are using the term rogue
devices so every company takes uh you
know
its own approach about what defies a
rogue device
one can define it you know a device that
operates layered three and a bob or
sometimes it's an application or
sometimes it's something in layer two uh
so the fact that you as a as a see so
you buy a you know a solution that you
know on the brochure promise you to
handle and mitigate rock devices then
you know you feel comfortable that say
oh i have this cupboard or if you buy a
neck solution and you know they promise
you they
you know the sky
um and then you you're certain that if
someone plugs in in one minute switch up
you will see this light you know like
this and it's not the case uh so it's uh
it's a lot of misconceptions especially
with everything that has to do with usb
devices this is something that still
puzzles me
you know usb vulnerabilities are being
you know for decades probably in the the
oldest you know malicious type of
interface
and uh obviously android security edr
solution xdr they all handle a usb to
some extent some of them even ha you
know say we have a bad usb module
and when you go into a c zone you ask
him okay do you uh what is your usb
policy and then he would say oh well we
do not allow usb devices
and when we you know will ask him okay
how do you type how do you navigate this
oh
a keyboard and a mouse and how are they
connected oh then that's through a usb
so for some unknown reasons uh the
the keyboard and mouse are
treated differently
than uh other you know usb mass storage
which is you know most dlp and input
security wheel block cameras and so on
and obviously if this is uh the device
that is allowed to connect guess where
the attackers will target they'll target
the mouse and
and and keyboards that's you know why
so so many adapters coming up from hack
five or uh a obg cables ninja cables
they all
you know tick on the same uh
on the same item of of impersonating as
an hid device right so if you're looking
now on a company and i'm specifically
curious about your own position you're
you're co-founder but you're also the
chief marketing officer at a different
role
than what i've seen you've held
previously transitioning you know for
more very technical cto level to now
more of the marketing and understanding
the market and focusing on that what
what made you decide to make that
personal switch and what you're dealing
with in the day-to-day
so first of all it's uh
it's because of two things first of all
it's uh it's a challenge i i love i love
the challenge and uh i think that
in order to uh
to bring this new concept this you uh
term of
zero trust hardware access into the
market you need to come with some uh you
know qualification and the level of
professionals so people will listen
because you know
at the beginning it was like you know
trench uh war you know we had to uh to
persuade people that this is an issue
you had to uh
do a lot of what i call you know the the
awareness campaign through analysts and
through uh
a key stakeholders and you have to
convince them and you can only do that
by having you know the
the relevant and and data and the
information and qualification because if
you you wouldn't have then you've been
brushed off you know in a minute saying
oh we have that covered it's not a
problem in and then you need someone as
a counterweight
and uh
going back to my earlier comment you
know we've uh we've been working as a
group of founders and you know each one
of us is a piece of the puzzle uh
someone answers the ceo and the other is
the you know the beginning was the uh
responsible for the engineering product
so you know we were like a team and each
one has its own strengths so well you
know i happily took this uh this
challenge
upon myself i love it so so tell me a
little bit about you know
but i'm sure that the technology is
fascinating to you but specifically
because we're talking about a market
education piece
and i'm specifically interested about go
to market and marketing for for a
company like this what what have you
been observing that works really well
with sort of educating the market on a
need even for a solution like this
because at the end you're you're talking
about taking somebody who may not be
ready to to to accept it
you know as a technologist and as an
entrepreneur that this is something that
they probably need
how do you go that mile to get them to
where you're staying
so um so obviously you you have to have
the first wins and uh
that you could then use as references
and those will be your ambassadors for
it
for educating the market because
uh you know one man can you know can
have all the limited outreach you know
there are only certain hours of the day
so if you're selling you're able to
convince five then those files become
your ambassadors of
hardware access control then that would
be that would be great now in order to
find those uh those first early adopters
then you need to look for those very
unique unique c cells um because uh i
kind of categorized the c cells as the
the evangelizing see so those are the
one who you know they get it they really
get it they uh they understand the risks
they're they're not a afraid of uh of
experimenting even when the with younger
startups and they happily adopt the the
solution once you prove them the value
and
the other the other kind will be the
followers that they will look up to the
evangelizing see so they will see that
they are doing well and then they will
follow their footprints and there's the
amount of kind of cut and paste season
that you know they'll buy
whatever the others are buying so which
you have to have kind of gross release
of the one input security one dlp one an
egg so they'll they'll go with you know
kind of a
organized list so we've started with the
he with the evangelizing system we were
fortunate enough to uh
to have some of the
most intelligent
professional seasons that
we came to meet in our long career
and uh once they've adopted it and then
some of them you know ran organization
like you know 50 000 employees 20 000
employees which for uh or a young
startup in its first year to get a
customer of that scale is is phenomenal
especially if it's something coming out
for the financial which is more
uh heavy on logistics and bureaucracy
and once we got these uh these
references then you know they've
actually took us by the end to their
peers and to their colleagues and we've
kind of propagated through there and you
know as uh
as the years uh you know moved on we
there were more incidents there were
more uh
people arguing for this domain so now
gartner has this uh domain which is a
cyber physical security which deals with
the
this entire concept of hardware-based
attacks the supply chain and their
regulations like section 889 in the us
and
and the fcc telco build there's a lot of
uh a work being done around this there
was obviously the bloomberg series and
there's a lot of you know back wind to
uh to what we're doing and it's like
three years ago i had to explain is this
problem really happening is this stuff
really happening or it's just you know
self-made story uh then this is no
longer the case people are responsive
and uh yeah we see that in our business
results so what it sounds to me is that
you you have a strategy for how do you
take a market that is right now still
pretty young or it's in its infancy of
understanding and there's okay we're we
still believe it's a problem we can
still start selling it and we'll get a
validation through some some strong
partners that are working with us
initially for the validation but we have
to understand that parallel to us those
the world is getting educated with or
without us in this matter and so over
time our marketing strategy is actually
going to become a little bit easier or
more trivial for for the world to
understand because a lot of this extra
education that we have to do it's
getting solved by this parallel path
that the world is on right
yeah and uh and you know besides the
marketing the the sales activities are
are completely different because you
know because you're not selling endpoint
security number 17 then you know the
the people that you need in order to
sell your product are more of a kind of
a
even entrepreneur in in nature like
bsdev type of oriented
rsms so that you know they could uh
find their way in and explain the
problem and find those opportunities and
and only when
once we get that opportunity secure then
we could bring in you know the standard
you know resellers and distributors to
actually go and and run the logistics of
the incredible incredible what is the
part you know you've been doing this for
a while you've been cyber security
veteran for many years
continuing to build a new company now uh
which has been running for some time but
but still deciding to go on on yet
another company journey what where's the
thrill for you what do you enjoy most
about this whole thing
so i think that uh i enjoy the roller
coaster atmosphere of
of being estonia because there are
hind eyes and lolos you know they're
like wigs that you know
you you know you you don't want to get
out of bed because it's been such a
such a horrible way because you know
it's something that you've been working
on or a submission for a certain
award that didn't come through or
something like that
uh or a campaign that you know didn't
bring the good result uh so you have
those laws but on the other hand you
have you know when you do get those say
highways of uh of winning and obtaining
customers and you get good feedbacks on
uh on a piece of content that you've
created whether it's a video or
or someone said oh i wrote i read your
white paper and i thought it would say
it was great um
so i i enjoy the the thrill of that high
lows and uh and the challenge you know
we're building something is something
new we're not cutting pasting anything
uh we're inventing a new domain which is
a nightmare seo wise uh because you know
probably not a lot of people are looking
for a hardware access control but we're
changing that and uh
and we'll succeed you know we
we're
originally israeli so there's no like
can't do it uh attitude it's all you
know it's just a matter of time when
we're getting what we got i love it i
love it betsy i really want to thank you
for time the energy 20 minutes go by
very very fast and and i'm really
thankful for friday for the work and for
the time that you've spent here and i
learned a lot myself so thank you very
much and best of luck with said pr stay
safe and stay healthy
[Music]